I was having a discussion with Sam
Harris the other day,
which was very,
um,
what would you say?
He said we got wrapped around an axle,
which is pretty much hate.
Sam Harris is one of the four famous
atheists along with Christopher Hitchens
and Richard Dawkins and Dan Dennett.
Yeah.
And so we were having a discussion and
um,
he's a determinist just right down to
the bottom.
It's like you're determined,
you're determined.
There's no freewill.
You're a deterministic machine.
And you know,
if you're a coherent scientist and
you're a Newtonian,
roughly speaking,
you don't really have much choice other
than to think that way,
but that isn't how it seems to people
and we don't treat each other that way.
And our entire legal system is
predicated on the idea that you do in
fact have freewill.
So.
Well,
can we account for it?
no.
And do we have a scientific model for
it?
No,
but then I would also say we do not have
a scientific model for consciousness.
We don't know a damn thing about
consciousness,
which is why Dan Dennett book,
which was called consciousness
explained,
was referred to.
It's by it's critics as consciousness
explained a way,
which is exactly right as far as I'm
concerned because he took a mechanistic
approach and I just don't think you get
to do that because there's something
really weird about consciousness.
I mean,
th,
the phenomenologists Heidegger,
who tried to radically transform western
philosophy right from the bottom up,
he basically said,
well,
you know,
you can treat the world as if
consciousness is primary and that human
experience is reality.
That's reality and that he doesn't exist
independently of consciousness in any
explicable way.
It's like,
well,
what's out there?
If there's nothing to to experience it?
Well,
everything at once.
It's something like that.
It's,
it's not really comprehensible as
without a subject that subject defines
it.
It makes it real.
Now you don't have to believe that,
but,
but at least I'm telling you that there
are thoroughly coherent philosophical
positions that make that case very
strongly and that that allow
consciousness to exist as a phenomena
and to take it seriously and you
certainly act like you take it
seriously.
You Act like there's a you and that you
make choices and you certainly treat
other people that way.
Deterministic or not,
you're still going to get angry when
they're being rude to you and you're
going to act as if they had some choice
in the matter.
Now maybe that's an illusion possibly,
but maybe it's not.
And I would say the oldest stories that
we have always include that as not only
as a fundamental element,
but even as the fundamental element so.
Well,
so you can think about that however you
want.
But anyways,
so Japan comes along and he's going to
finish off the puppet.
And so what does he do to finish off the
puppet?
He gives it a.
it's,
it gives it a voice.
It gives it a mouth.
Well,
that's really,
really interesting.
So in Genesis,
in Genesis,
this is a,
this is a very,
very complex idea and it took people
thousands of years to figure this idea
out and it's something like this is so
at the beginning of everything,
there was chaos and that was like
potential.
It was something like potential,
the potential for being and God who is
God?
The father in the genesis account uses a
faculty that he has,
which is the word to call being from
chaos knots,
the creation of Ba,
right?
It's the.
It's the manifestation of order from
chaos and it's the word,
the logos that it's.
It's the logos.
That's the tool that God uses to do that
and that logos in Christianity is
associated with Christ,
which is a very weird thing,
but the reason for that is that there's
an idea that the divine element of the
individual is the thing that uses
language,
communicative language to call the world
into being,
and that is what we do as far as we can
tell.
It's like you make a decision.
You think it through,
you talk it over with your friends,
you plot a course and the world
manifests itself in relationship to your
choice and it's for that reason and it
is for that reason that in genesis and
in many other accounts that that logo's
capacity is identified with human
beings.
It's like you have a small bit of that
in you.
Whatever that means,
and you participate in the process of
continually generating order out of
chaos and and sometimes the reverse,
you mediate between them and so and that
is that in our,
in,
in Western culture and certainly the
case at other cultures as well,
that that's why you have rights.
Fundamentally.
That's why the law has to respect you is
because you've got this spark of
divinity in you that's transcendent that
nobody gets to transgress against and
you say,
well,
do you believe that?
It's like,
well,
you act like you believe it.
You treat other people like you believe
it or they're not very happy with you.
So it depends on what you mean by
believe you acted out well.
Do you accept it as a proposition?
Oh,
I don't care if you accept that as a
proposition,
frankly,
because I think the best indicator of
what you believe is how you act.
Not what you say because what do you
know about what you know?
Hardly anything and so actions speak
louder than words and if you want to be
treated properly by someone,
what that means is that you want to
treat them,
you want them to treat you as a valuable
autonomous entity.
That's what you want.
And so maybe you're not that.
Maybe you're a deterministic puppet and
what this strange movie suggests is that
you are kind of a deterministic puppet,
but that you don't have to be all right,
well you,
the mouth goes on and then Japan was
happy about that and then they have a
little dance,
you know,
they,
they turn the music on and all these
little music boxes and they all play
together and it's like harmony of some
sort has been established because that's
what the music represents and the,
there's layers of reality that are
communicating with one another because
that's what the music represents.
And then they have a little dance and
the idea is that,
well,
it's a good thing to let this puppet
habits own voice.
Well,
that's an interesting idea because what
the hell does it?
No,
it's a wooden headed marionette.
Why the hell would you want something
like that to talk?
Well,
it's the same question you have in
relationship to your children.
It's like what do they know?
They're two or three,
you know,
they don't know anything.
Well,
so should you just like tyrannized them
and make them do everything you want?
Are you going to let them have a bit of
a voice?
And the question is,
it depends on whether do we want them to
be a puppet or not.
And if you don't want them to be a
puppet,
if you want them to grow up autonomous,
then you let them have a voice and you
facilitate the development of that voice
and so and,
and,
and that's.
And that's what you do if you don't want
a marionette.
So,
and Japan who doesn't want a marionette.
So he gives the puppet of voice even
though he knows it's just a puppet and
that it's,
it doesn't know anything.
And then this is fantastic.
So the cricket sitting up there watching
that,
he's pretty happy with it.
That's the first little seed and you see
there and he's sitting by this other
thing that is just not happy at all and
if that's the terrible father and you
see it's a character that repeats
throughout the entire movie.
You see manifestations of the tyrannical
father continually through the movie in
different characters.
Like he's played out by different roles.
And so first of all,
the cricket is so thrilled about this.
And then he looks at the frowning king
there who's,
who is not happy that the puppet has
been given a voice.
He's a tyrant,
right?
He's the representation of a tyrant and
a tyrant does not want you to have a
voice.
And so the cricket looks at him and
says,
well,
you can't please everybody all the time.
And it's just this tiny little fragment
of a joke,
you know.
But it's,
there's this old idea.
I think it comes from Chekhov and,
and the idea is that if you set a
playoff and there's a gun,
a rifle or a pistol on a table in the
first act,
it better have been used by the third
act.
Or it shouldn't have been there at all
and the idea is you don't put anything
in your play that it's random.
You never do that.
It's like,
because this isn't life,
that,
that this isn't life.
This is a work of art and everything is
connected and it's caught know it's
there by intent.
And so this isn't accidental that this
little king character doesn't like
what's going on or that he shows up.
So anyways,
all,
all the clocks go off and the music
boxes go and they have a little dance
and everybody's happy about it.
And,
and then Japan notices what time it is.
And so there's a tremendous emphasis on
time in this part of the movie because
there are all these clocks are going off
and they're all telling him what time it
is.
Like 30 clocks go off and then he takes
his watch out and notices what time it
is.
It's like the idea that there's
something about going on is like whack
that you,
you know,
dozens of times so that you get it.
And it's a little joke that he pulls out
his watch and he figures out it's time
for bed.
Well,
so now we're making a transition between
the conscious world and the unconscious
world.
Okay.
So,
so there's an intimation in the movie
that everything that happens now is in
the unconscious world.
And the way you know that is that it's,
it's strange because the movie moves in
and out of this underworld.
But at the very end,
when Pinocchio's transformed into a real
boy,
the last thing Japan does is I think
it's Japan always hit one of the
pendulums and start all the clocks
again.
So it says,
if what happens from here onwards is
part of a dream,
now it's,
it's murky because Pinocchio goes to
school and you know,
there's the next day and all of that.
But.
And so those are sort of realistic
elements.
But then there's also the whole going
down into the ocean to find the whale
thing,
which seems completely dreamlike and,
but there's an intimation that we're in
a different kind of world.
And,
and so we go to,
they all go to sleep,
including the cricket.
And so then Japan,
oh,
notices the star and because he's a good
guy,
he makes a wish on the start and we've
already explained why you might wish on
a star and what that might mean.
And He makes it very interesting wish.
Um,
it's,
it's not a self serving wish.
In fact,
it's quite the contrary.
He doesn't wish that Pinocchio is an
obedient son.
He doesn't wish that he's produced
someone who will work for him.
He doesn't wish any of that.
He wishes what a good father would wish,
which is that the creation that he's
brought forth would develop its capacity
for autonomy.
He wants them to become real.
He wants him to become an actual living
creature and not a wooden headed
marionette.
And so you'd say,
well,
that is what your father should wish for
you.
You know,
and I have clients frequently whose
fathers weren't like that at all.
They were to radical or they were
neglectful or,
or they punish this person every time
they did something good.
That's a real fun game.
They competed with them and undermining
them at every opportunity.
They didn't want to produce someone
strong.
And autonomous,
they wanted to give birth to a slave and
then diminish it as much as possible.
And so that's bad.
It's not good and not so Japan was not
like that.
So he says,
well,
I'm going to wish for something
completely unreasonable,
which is that part of that ideal idea,
right?
And they're unreasonable thing is that
this puppet could become
real,
could actually take on its autonomy and,
and move forward.
And so that's what he wishes.
And then they go to sleep
and then the cricket starts to become
driven mad by the noises of the clock.
And so it's like he's going into the
sort of,
of hyper alertness and the clocks are
clanging.
Adam and Jupiter was snoring and,
and that he can even hear the little
grains of sand falling out of the,
out of the our glass.
He's becoming hyper alert,
hyper alert,
and then he yelled,
stop.
And all the clock stop.
Which is pretty good trick for cricket,
you know,
it's like he's the master of time.
But also we're in a place now where time
has come to a stop or outside of time.
And one of the things that Freud pointed
about,
dreams is that dreams are kind of
outside of time.
Now,
here's what that means is first of all,
they draw and eternal themes.
That's part of it.
But you know,
he must have had this experience.
And Freud noted this carefully in the
interpretation of dreams where you know
you're sleeping and the alarm goes off
and the alarm noise is incorporated into
your dream.
And it's like the dream has been going
on for an hour in subjective time.
And you wake up and you realize that
it's the alarm clock.
It's like.
And there's no reason why your dream
time should be the same as real time
because it's all going on in your
imagination.
But it's amazing in some sense how much
can happen in such a short period of
time in your imagination.
And so it's outside of time.
The world of fantasy is in some sense
out of outside of time.
And so the cricket tells time to stop
and it does.
And then the star enlarges and it turns
into this blue fairy who's got a
celestial gown covered with stars.
And who's got wings,
so she's kind of some ethereal being and
like you don't have a problem with that
in the movie.
It's like,
yeah,
sure.
I mean,
you know,
it's a ferry.
It came from a star.
That makes perfect sense,
which of course it does.
It makes no sense whatsoever.
Right?
It makes no sense,
but you're willing to go along with it
because on the one hand it makes sense.
No sense.
And on the other hand it makes perfect
sense.
It's like the fairy godmother idea.
It's like,
yeah,
fairy God,
mother,
no problem.
We,
we got that.
And it's in the idea there is that while
nature comes to your aid,
it's something like that.
It's,
it's,
it's the benevolent force of nature is
on your side now,
not obviously only on your side because
it opposes you as well,
but then there's your own mother as well
who's also nature,
who's on your site.
And so,
but there's an idea here and the idea is
that if the father gets the wish right,
the aim right for the child,
then nature will cooperate.
Right?
And that's true.
I believe that's true.
Is that if you set up your relationship,
your cultural relationship with your
child properly,
then they're far more likely to flourish
and so you get the magic of nature on
your side by establishing the proper
aim.
And so that's what happens.
Japan.
Oh says,
well,
this is what I'm.
This is what I'm aiming at and because
he's aiming at at it and because it's
within the realm of possibility,
nature comes to his service and that is
how it works.
That's exactly how it works because when
you aim at something,
then you muster your biological forces
towards that goal and if the goal is
feasible and attainable,
then you will cooperate with yourself.
And so that's quite cool.
Carl Rogers would call that.
What's the word for that?
I think he called a genuineness,
which is kind of weak,
but.
But I think.
I think that's still what he called it.
He sort of meant that.
Well,
that's sort of what happens when your,
when your goals and your physiological
and biological being are aligned well
and you're and you can communicate both.
You're not full of internal
contradictions and so your conscious
aims and your biological possibilities
are manifesting themselves in the same
direction.
And so while that would be good,
so anyways,
the fairy shows up and she's quite
sexually attractive.
She's quite provocative and she,
she charms the cricket and who gets all
blushes and like is all,
you know,
embarrassed and overwhelmed by this like
figure of celestial beauty and decides
to cooperate.
That conscience decides to cooperate and
get some responsibility.
And so the ferry allows the puppet to
move without strings.
So that's kind of interesting.
So it's the intervention of nature.
Culture focuses the aim and then it's
the intervention of nature that produces
the autonomy and that seems to be right.
I mean,
even though it's not that
understandable,
it seems to be right.
And then so she takes the strings off
Pinocchio and you might say,
well,
that's partly because your child is not
certainly not just a creature of
culture.
By no means your child has a
temperament.
You'll see that right away and that
temperament will unfold and hopefully
it'll unfold in a cultural context
that's amenable to it.
And that the combination of those two
things will produce something new,
he can talk,
he can walk,
and so the good fairy basically tells
him that he's got a bit of autonomy and
now it's up to him to like clue in Tibet
and act properly and learn the
difference between good and evil and to
speak truthfully and all that.
It's a bit a propagandistic that part of
the movie I would say,
but it doesn't really matter.
It's kind of inculcation of conventional
morality and there's a fair bit to it,
especially that he's supposed to tell
the truth.
And uh,
you know,
he says he will.
And the crickets listening.
And then the puppet asks,
well,
what does conscience mean?
Because the ferry says,
always let your conscience be your
guide.
And he says,
well,
what does consciousness mean?
And then the bug who's like all puffed
up because he wants to impress the
ferry,
plops down and gets on his little
matchbox and gives this like horrible
little lecture about how to behave
properly.
That's just like ideological chatter.
You could hardly even stand listening to
it.
And it's supposed to be like that.
It's generic moral advice that anyone
could give that's kind of dull and,
and also puffed up and grandiose and
he's just not very good at it.
So,
and that's why he's on his little
matchbox there with his chest puffed
out.
And so he says that's just the travel
with the world today.
And uh,
and I think that's his opening line,
you know,
he's diagnosing the whole world and you
know,
the fairy,
she thinks he's kind of funny because he
is and you know,
it's sort of,
there's a real interesting thing here
going on because he's male and he's,
he's all puffed up with his knowledge,
which is completely shallow.
And then he's put in contact with this
celestial feminine ideal and he just
turns into a complete moron.
And that's exactly what happens to man.
It happens to them all the time.
So anyways,
she decides to give them a chance and
turns them into this conscience and all
of a sudden he's this like 19 twenties
millionaires.
So He's been,
he's been ennobled,
but then she tells him that,
you know,
he has to journey along with Pinocchio
in order for things to go properly and
he promises that he'll be a good
conscience and do it and he already
thinks that he can do it and that's why
he's on the matchbox podium,
you know,
espousing his morality.
But the reality turns out to be much
more complex.
So the bug has a little talk with the
cricket or the bug has a little talk
with the puppet and the Bug tries to
tell Pinocchio explicitly what it means
to be good and he gets completely
tangled up in the explanation because
what the hell does he know?
And the,
the Papa doesn't understand anything
that he says anyways.
And so there's a message there and the
message is the kind of knowledge that
the conscience is that the conscience
and the puppet are supposed to cocreate
is not something that you can articulate
easily as a table of rules.
It's not like that because life is too
complicated to just have fought five
rules that you live by and that will
solve every problem.
Partly because the rules will conflict.
That's a huge part of the problem,
right?
One moral guideline contradicts another
ines situations like you don't know what
to do.
So anyways,
they decided that there they decided
that they're just going to.
He says,
Pinocchio says,
well I'll be a good boy,
and the cricket says,
well that's the spirit,
and then,
well then Japan,
oh,
gets wind of it and they have a little
like horror episode and then he finds
out that the public can is autonomous
and they have a little party which tells
you exactly what your pedals up to is.
The autonomy emerges and he's happy
about it.
So it's stamping home the notion that
Japan is in fact a good guy and that
that is in fact what he wants.
So it's like the encouragement of your
father is a precondition for the
emergence of your individuality and,
and it also allows the feminine to play
a role both as nature and perhaps as
mother and so and the combination of
those two produces the autonomous
individual.
It's like,
well,
that seems perfectly reasonable.
So off they go to sleep,
next day they wake up and it's a new day
and,
and Pinocchio is off to school and
that's a good thing too because Japan
isn't and he's really excited about it.
And so what that means is that he's been
parented properly and he's going to go
out into the world of his peers,
which is where he belongs.
And Japan isn't too worried about it.
In fact,
he is pushing them out the door,
you know,
it's like go,
you can do it,
this is the next thing.
The kid isn't cowering in the corner and
overcome by terror with the parents
freaking out about all the things that
are going to go wrong.
It's,
there's some faith in his,
his ability.
So he sees all the kids wandering by
and,
and Japan,
no dresses them up and sends them off to
school and so and so.
That's good.
So that's a happy family story.
It's like mom and dad got together.
They decided that there,
the kid was gonna,
you know,
be competent and autonomous and ready to
face the world.
And so Audi goals and so he's like five
years old at this point or something
like that and that's where we get,
that's where we're at in the story and I
think that's a good place to stop
because the next thing that happens is
normally essentially it's like Pinocchio
goes off to be a good boy,
but it turns out that that's a hell of a
lot more complicated than he might think
because there are actually complications
in the world,
but also malevolence right?
The desire for things not to go right.
There are people who are not oriented
towards the ideal in any way.
Adult and Pinocchio's young and naive
and so he has no defense whatsoever
against this malevolence and that's,
you know,
that's not an expect,
not unexpected.
And it also turns out that the
conscience,
the cricket,
who is still not very clued in over
sleeps.
And so he's just not there at a critical
moment.
But I think we'll pick that up.
We'll pick that up next week because
this is a good point in the plot to stop
the child has entered the broader world
and has to cope with it.
And so he's prepared because he had a
wonderful father and he had a magical
mother and so he's as prepared as you
can be.
He's not even completely a marionette
anymore,
but,
but now it's up to him.
That's the thing.
Now it's up to him and his parents have
done basically what they could.
And that's really about right.
You know,
um,
it's,
it's wise.
I would say psychologically.
So.
Alright,
that's,
that.